i'm always comparing it to taking our ai
to a design school understanding the
fundamental of design once we have that
then we know
the individuals you know based on either
previous actions they've done or based
on the style quiz we can truly create
custom recommendation for each shopper
and i think the way that we approach it
that's what makes us unique and that's
what makes big brands really interesting
in what we do
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact leap google
for startups and hippo and in media
partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders today we're talking
about home decorations and creativity
and how to meet the intersection of the
two and how perhaps through technology
we can allow people to
choose design and decorate the way that
their spaces are
something that i'm personally interested
in
meet along giladi
along graduated with a bachelor's of
arts in economics and philosophy from
tel aviv university he is a serial
entrepreneur based in tel aviv
during his last year at university he
founded a startup company in the sports
and entertainment collectibles industry
he signed big licensing deals with
significant brands such as fc barcelona
man city nba wwe and disney selling over
1.5 million units through major
retailers in europe and the united
states in 2017 he co-founded a 3d
rendering studio creating virtual
reality experiences for architects and
interior designers from the knowledge
and experience gaining in this venture
the idea of renovai was born with an
ambitious mission to empower online
retailers with ai to make professional
design and stylist services affordable
and accessible for all and fun facts
specifically that i'm really excited
about here is that he was a professional
poker player during university so alon
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for being here you're not going
to say this yourself but i will to the
audience you are sick today and you uh
and i and i offered to reschedule this
but this is exactly why i love the show
so much because you're so passionate
about what you do that regardless of how
you're feeling you're here and you're
about to passionately inspire me with
everything that you do so thank you so
much alone for making the time to be
here today how are you
i'm i'm okay thank you for having me
michael it's pleasure to be here and i
wouldn't even visit
awesome i love it well alone i'll get
started right away first of all serial
entrepreneur entrepreneurship runs
through your runs through your veins
today you're the you're running renovai
and you're looking at home decorations
making it fun accessible looking at
technology to disrupt this field how do
you get started with home renovations
and and decorations how does one
get themselves involved with the scene
[Music]
it's a long story
we have all day
a short one yeah
so
in my first company that me and the lawn
chairman built together one of our
employees
was a brilliant 3d artist
and we thought once the company was
closed and we thought about ways to take
advantage of his
capability
and build
something
so we decided to build a 3d studio
basically we have hired him and a bunch
of armored 3d artists
and we
went to interior interior designers
architects real estate developers and we
have created
3d visualizations of apartments and
buildings and so on
and
so from that experience
we thought about renovai and we fell in
love in the in the lead interesting what
was the big
the big opportunity that you saw
with with that you got exposed to
through the inspiration of 3d design and
that world
with with ren with what randomized today
and maybe it will actually be helpful to
start with a little bit about what
renovi is today and then let's bridge
the gap from the inspiration to
actualization
yeah so honestly i think
the main
really exciting thing the opportunity
that we saw
is that
designers have potter
so
let's say they try to design a
scandinavian living room we saw patterns
between different designers and within
desires
and
in that specific moment we thought a lot
and and myself we thought there's an
opportunity trying to understand
what is a good design how to mimicate
the way that interior designers think
about the process
and
so yeah i thought this is super exciting
because it's involve
a
deep technology and
business and
we thought there was a huge opportunity
yeah the first goal was to build a
full interior designer and doing a
direct consumer a company
but within time we have pivot a bit but
the main idea is is the same to build
the capability of designing as if our ai
was a real interior designer design
so taking a step back and looking a
little bit about you know why you do
what you do tell me a little bit about
the intersection of you
and technology you and entrepreneurship
you and design
how does alone fit into this whole
construct that you just shared with me
here
what story does this play for you
so i think
i love building
things and being creative
and
may i say leading people
and i think i do it in a different way
and i think i'm doing it well since my
days in in the army
and
so i love to do that
the first company that myself and alone
built was
in a completely different field
not high tech
but we were always excited about that my
two brothers
are software developers and algorithm
developers so
yeah i was inspired by them and i'm not
i i'm not from that domain my academic
background is economics and philosophy
but i knew that i'm going to build
something that
involves technology
someday and
and building things so yeah that's the
main reason why i'm here and
the specific reason why i'm interior
designer is
basically luck
we got to to understand the domain we
got to work in the domain and it's fun
it's
sexy i think we're not in our you know
cyber company which could be a great
thing but i think it's more exciting and
visual
and
and then we are working with a variety
of different people you know from
interior designers that are in the
company to
really healthy ai engineers
and we have the full variety and
and it's cool it's it's exciting
tell me a little bit more about this fun
that you're describing here you're
talking about you know
you know obviously not another cyber
company that it's very innovative you're
in a vertical that you don't really see
on the day-to-day
tell me a little bit about your personal
experience working with design interior
designers chain you know helping people
reimagine how their home would be
through technology what is that
experience like for you
so are you asking about employees or are
you asking about end consumers
either either and or
not enough
yeah so
it's a challenge and
exciting so i try to describe that so
my thinking is very analytic
so i understand
what we need to do and how to do things
however that specific domain involves a
lot of you know soft skills
and we need to to make
the interior design team
understand the ai departments
and the ai department understand you
know the soft skills of interior
designers right and
that's a process that's a very
interesting process to to try to
get
the goods from every every world and
make the system dynamic enough to really
try to mitigate the
the work and the type of person that
works with me are completely different
you know ai engineers are certain type
of people and interior designers are
really different and i think that's what
makes the company really unique and fun
to work with the variety of characters
in the company is a
is really a good mix
i love it tell me a little bit about the
vision
so how does the world look like
a few years down the line let's say
eight years from today
renova is totally successful you've
managed to meet all the milestones
you're looking for how is
how are things different either in home
decoration space in any other space due
to the success of renovai
i'll take it i think a step backwards
describing what we do
so right now yeah we are a bit too big
to see company so we are selling our
software
to e-commerce
retailers within the home decor world
and we try to help the retailers to make
a better experience trying to help the
end consumer in every different touch
point they might have across the website
and alongside the customer journey and
making decision
more fun easier
and more design oriented compared to
anything else so that's basically the
type of
business model that we are working with
um and we want to be the best player in
the whole decor world so making
life and customer journey throughout the
different websites across the globe
an easy one and and
the way it was intended you know uh
online and interior design is hard and i
think our solution could make life
much easier and yeah and much more fun
and and so so now looking a little bit
into the future so
what is the disruption in the home
decoration space looks like how how does
the success of of renovate look like
maybe maybe we can even start from from
the end consumer so from the people
reimagining the way that their homes
could be designed and could look
how does that impact sort of my ability
to take ownership or reduce ownership i
don't know about how i how my home is
so as i mentioned we try to build every
touch point the customer might have with
the website so either
for example if you're looking for a
specific item
we have a product we call scout that
designated to help the customer to find
the perfect item based on
style elements the soft skill
and we try to recommend not just based
on you know sheer
filters we try to understand
what's the motivation of the customer
and what type of style and confidence
they're looking for and that's how to
recommend
the second second step we we are really
able to help customers to
buy bundles of products and trying to
design a full space
and so if you are for example looking to
redesign a living room
based on a few questions and the style
quiz we understand the most important
things about you
about your needs about your requirements
about your style
and based on that we are able to offer
the best bundle of items together and we
can show that the final result could be
in
in beautiful 3d photorealistic rooms or
an interactive woodwords it doesn't
matter our core ip is the capability to
understand
design in a very fundamental way
understand the shopper knowing the
inventory and based on that
truly create a customer accommodation
and personalized accommodation for each
individual chapter
interesting and so is that what i'm
hearing here is a byproduct of a
consumer behavior is that potentially
you're you're you're allowing right
right now right if i if i want to
redesign my living room i would
essentially either have to
to do it myself which is a tedious
process because i don't really know what
i want i know maybe to describe what i
like in general but it's hard for me to
pick and choose or i would get an
interior designer to go and choose stuff
for me
now what you're saying is that you're
able to translate sort of my personality
and and things that i like in your and
you're able to be that that sort of that
bridge between my creative self which
everybody has that part of them then
translating that to the actionable
design that you could provide
in in in a photorealistic way so that i
could actually perceive it and give you
feedback right
exactly
my only comment about about it is it
doesn't have to be in a photorealistic
way one of the solution is
photorealistic the other ones could be
in different ways so for for example we
are doing a mood mode without
3d at all
our core value is
basically understand you and understand
your personality and understand the
style preferences that you have and
based on that finding the right items
which is a very hard task you know some
of the retailers that we are working
with has over 200 000 items it's
basically impossible to do that and
i know that most of the people that are
i'm talking to think about other
augmented reality solutions in the world
you know there's a lot of companies that
doing
augmented reality uh virtual reality and
so on
but the major barrier for the end
consumer is still finding the right
items trying to match items together and
this is the main problem that we try to
solve we say look we're going to
recommend you within seconds the best
items for you
based on a deep understanding of
what goes well with what
and what suits you and
yeah i think that's natural what we try
to do
and how how granular do you get in the
what suits you right because i mean we
have a lot of different technologies for
sorting through e-commerce and tagging
and classifying you know products online
i think what what's really interesting
what you're saying here is this this
personalization aspect sort of this
how does michael fit into his home
decoration process because honestly i
hate shopping you can't make me go to a
furniture store in my life but if you
offer a solution for me to be able to
translate my personality and creativity
actionably into a into a decoration
process that results in okay these are
the items that will work for you in your
living room that's a big
that's a big game changer because right
now i have no way of translating my own
thoughts and personality
exactly and another really interesting
way that we think about the problem we
are not just another
recommendation ranger
you know most recommendations are based
on segmentation and statistical behavior
what basically we are doing i'll try to
elaborate that it's quite complicated
but imagine that we try to
understand what's
in good scandinavian living world is
in the wild
what we do is collecting thousands of
well-designed living rooms that our
interior designers think they are a
great representation of
of of that specific style
then we have computer vision that is
able to understand each of the items
inside the room
and on top of that we have statistical
engine that try to understand the
correlation between the items how
designers are matching colors and shapes
and textures and so on and so on
and i'm always comparing it to taking
our ai to a design school understanding
the fundamental of design once we have
that
then we know
the individuals you know based on either
previous actions they've done or based
on the style quiz we can truly create
custom recommendations for each shopper
and i think the way that we approach it
that's what makes us unique and that's
what makes big brands really interested
in what we do
interesting and so even internally where
you're when you're mentioning it's not
like that the
designers are working with your
researchers to fine-tune the model
they're actively creating models of
successful living room designs and then
you're basically giving that as a
labeled data set to your machine
learning researchers where are they able
to say okay now let's act as if this is
the real world and we're just getting
these images and let's learn from real
world scenarios using computer vision
exactly the
interior design team is very heavily
involved with the ai
element we are building
a knowledge graph which basically
creating a full terminology
and so there's a lot of work uh to be
done from the interior design world and
specifically to trade the ai in
phenomenal amazing so so going back to
that original vision you know running
this company
you're looking a few years down the line
what what what
what what is sort of a a
i guess a meaningful change
that you're personally excited for
due to renovai you know when you wake up
or when you talk to your all hands
meeting or when you think through the
vision of renova what what meaningful
step does this make
consumer behavior the world design you
know anything of that sort
i think that we're going to have one of
the most exciting features that they
cannot disclose but this is
basically the major
new area of visual search i believe that
we have a great use case and we think
about the problem differently
and
so hopefully within a couple of years
from today the entire experience would
be
or parts of the experience would be
different
using our technology there's a lot of
companies that do
visual search
i think that our solution is going to be
quite unique within the
within the domain so this is the most
exciting part i i feel that
our solution is
obviously there's some business side to
the to to what we do but
to translate interior design into an ai
machine i think that's
that's what got me from from from the
first minute i'm always comparing it to
i know if you know ai was able to
understand how bath
is creating music and it was able to
create
full
pieces
completely automatic and expert would
not know
if it's an ai or bach and this is
exactly the thing that excites me
i'm hoping that someday our machine was
would be able to create designs that
are better compared to even top
designers around the globe
awesome i love that and i think that you
know from this conversation at least
what's excited me about the vision and
about the prospect is that it will allow
people like myself who today are very
limited in my ability to translate my
thoughts into actionable designs i get
tired quickly and i often find that i'm
not able to really translate my words if
i'm if i'm able to end up being able to
design my own spaces which is something
that i guess i'm sure that i'm not the
only one in the world who's having
trouble with that and that that that
sort of that commoditization of being
able to design things um
following my personal fundamental belief
that everybody's creative and everybody
is able to harness their creativity just
we're not able to to communicate it the
same way and i think that's a pretty
pretty big deal so alone thank you very
very much wish you best of luck with
renovai thank you for coming here even
though you're not feeling well and they
appreciate the relentlessness that it
takes to be an entrepreneur so thank you
again
cheers thank you michaels
you